and allow you an opportunity to establish a
p check was significant Improvement Ducks win
the draw Troy Terry who missed the last three
games with an upper body and throws it in just
20 seconds into the game welcome back Troy Terry
I think I think Trevor zers gets a stick on this
Puck on route to the goal negotiating that puck
along the blue line but you can see there was a
Red Wing right in his grill and that was Jake
wman that had chased him all the way out to
the blue line he throws it towards the net and
there's the hands of Trevor Jus look at that
bounce man that is a wicked bounce Alex lion
not much he can do about that lundestrom pops
out High got the little pass then spins away from
a falling Defender open his banine and good save
Alex lion he'll hold on oh nice play previous
meeting this season between between the two
teams and he's on his way to an All-Star Game
couldn't keep it in marching ahead it's drives
down and his shot fought off wings were two for
seven on the power play against the Ducks back on
the 18th of December at Little Caesar's Arena
you don't want to give him seven chances here
they come and that ra the crossbar and went out
of play he's looking to fire away he's trying to
go short side top shelf didn't miss by much
fabry inside the strike drops it off to pan
and got the spare shot tipped on the way just
wide Raymond got a little piece of that he'll
try again that's off the crossbar doall can't
cover pan wraps it to the corner and then gets
it back to the point Costas bear moves it and
pan not ready for that little pass from Lin as
he was in the bump position now Larin fires it
across the Zone Raymond rescues it 25 seconds
left in the power play lus Raymond hooks it back
gopar walks the line pan into the middle they
score Dylan Lin well was good Puck Movement by
the Red Wings right in the middle of the four
penalty killing forward or Duck players you see
Alex color just for a second allowed Dylan Lin
to get inside of him and that's why he was alone
Pon read that apparent icing so the Red Wings go
to work in the Anaheim Zone do stall got a glove
on it but he couldn't squeeze it it's loose for
Lucas Raymond and another penalty coming up to
Anaheim as chaos ensued after what should have
been an icing call Saw's going right to the
locker room a lot of chaos at the end there
good stop by D stal well you know it's you've got
a man Advantage so you know winning faceoffs Kane
did Brak it he hits the post that's already
the third post the wings of hit could to be
dangerous he threats a kn needle to Brink's got
half an ed to shoot at at even strength they're
minus 15 trying to go high short side on the
rush is lon who's back after leaving Midway
through that period Then Dylan Lin on the rush
tries to go short side up top only 10 seconds
left in the power play Lin rescues it at the
line goes rink wide with a comer again and a
glove save by doall couple of good stops be
just made on JT Comer oh excuse me that was
pan my bad sherat slips up the left boards
veteran defenseman brings it to the bottom
of the circle tries to make a pass poked Away by
the paddle of doall stick Andrew cop keeps it in
play wrap around attempt by valeno and that is
sealed off the officials are taking another look
at this you can see the pad of Lucas St Stall oh
boy and that does that puck go into the net and
back out it it's it's close to say the least hard
to tell from that angle but it looks like it may
have Cam now takes the lead pass out of the zone
and skates in into the slot Henrik got his own
rebound what a save by Alex Rush up the ice and
this drops it into a beautiful area for Adam Henri
gets his own rebound and that's the best save of
the night Ducks bust right back into the zone and
Terry takes out two def taking out two Defenders
excuse me it was Dale as the puck went to Terry
Terry has it left Circle Dale to McTavish one
timer got his own rebound over to Terry gloved
away sherat to the corner continues to spread the
ice zis to color right in front Mavis save made by
lion and it's cleared away confer will come out of
the box hard around it's tipped and Raymond down
at it Center for Detroit cross the top of the
slot drops it off Lin goes wide now behind the
net tries to wrap it around doall got the left
P Fus had it for a moment Kane races the other
way hands it off to fabri high slot dusted
off by comfor it's offer doall stays in the
barn things have opened up bakan and takes the
stretch pass from Gus gets Center ined hammers it
around and in color pushes it back behind the neet
rolls off a hit leaves it there for McTavish Mavis
great pass mov save oh lion didn't know where it
was it went to his left he thought it went to his
right the tronto works up the right board draws
two Defenders and ladles it back F to the middle
of the ice near circle strome on a t for Henri
glove save Alex lion from the top of the circle
know it's a you know one-timer by Henri who's got
a decent one-timer and now Jamie turns with it and
shovels it around the boards nobody home though
but Al o put it deep valeno in front for Kane and
it's banded Away by The Stick of Lucas doal right
now in the circle to the right of Alex lion at
last enri controls it patrono give go one timer
glove save by the Detroit net miners good setup
for the onetime you see vrono backing away just a
little bit and uh F offs in deep putting it in the
corner and then relying on the for check to create
turnovers second period is started and they're not
doing that rale just misses with a snapshot open
and zis score second of the game for Trevor zis
22 he's just kind of hanging out in that soft
area and he gets lost Detroit terries in the
middle and the pass goes all the way through
to zis it looked to me like Andrew cop got a
little bit lost behind the net he did he loses
Trevor zis for a split second and the Ducks make
him pay great shot look where that goes top
shelf for zis what a pass Daniel strong hands
it off gives it back Cider at the Line pass
came through great save th St they got the
look they wanted to Brink it snap that one off
a stop moments ago it was Kane to De Brink it
and just Blocker of dust off we're tied at two
7 minutes to go in regulation Dale picks off
a pass at Center and here's confer possible two
onone doto stares him down and kicks it [Music]
out fabry into the slot just mishandled by Lin
now Kane will take a shot and could save doall
back to the slot Lin F off by doall hard around
mnov but that's a turnover as sealing the wall was
Raymond over comes Raymond to collect the puck
cider shot TI in Michael rasmason with 67 seconds
left pass across cider's been very good
he saw that stick available but no it's
that's off the skate it's off the skate but
that's it'll take look at it of course but
is it a distinct kicking motion I don't think
so Terry rims it hard around Henri gets to it
with 15 seconds left kicks it up the wall Terry
from below the goal line turns fires lion got a
hand on it brush to the line but tono keeps it
in just pass up the boards with only 5 seconds
left and Anaheim can't get it to the front
of the net the wings are just going to eat
it in the Zamboni corner and as a result
Detroit wins tonight at Honda Center 3-2